[Music]
it's likely that many of us would have
heard tales of a rider in the dark that
has no head a headless horseman that
scours the countryside bringing death
and darkness to all those it comes
across stories of headless horsemen were
told in several European countries as
well as in many more from all around the
world but today's video will focus
mainly on the dullahan a spirit that
appears in the Irish folklore which also
means it can be classified as a fairy
but we're certainly not talking about
Tinker Bell nor the type of fairy they
each stick on top of your Christmas tree
now in this case the term fairy simply
refers to spirits and supernatural
entities found within European folklore
as with many aspects of Irish folklore
the Dullahan does have Celtic influences
stemming from the worship of chrome
Diouf a Celtic deity whose name meant to
the Dark One and who himself was thought
to have an African origin the worship of
chrome dev is often associated of human
sacrifice and perhaps that is why the
Dullahan is seen as a spirit that comes
to claim one soul it's usually depicted
as a headless rider dressed in black
riding a black horse though at times it
can be seen riding a carriage drawn by
six black horses which is usually
referred to as the silent coach or the
death coach this idea of the dullahan as
the coachman to the afterlife is an
interesting idea and one that we will
discuss later in some more detail now
back to the rider iteration of the
Dullahan despite being what many
considered to be the Headless Horseman
the Dullahan wasn't always seen as a man
as many believes they could also appear
as a female but there's no discernible
differences between the male and female
version they both still rode a black
horse and carried their head around with
them little harness most commonly
depicted as a male figure the head of
the Dullahan may not be attached to its
shoulders but that doesn't mean that
it's not of any use the head itself is
described as having an ever-present
sinister grin with eyes that constantly
move from left
and whose glare can be seen in the
darkest of night there were stories that
saved the head of the horsemen has been
imbued with supernatural sight that
allows the horsemen to see great
distances by lifting his head up high
above where his head should have been
the doula harkens count the land before
setting out on his right so one exactly
does the dullahan do other than roam the
countryside looking menacing we
mentioned earlier that those who come
across the dullahan rarely lived to tell
the tale but some do survive it said
that if you are not who the horseman
seeks but are still unlucky enough to
cross his path he may spare you but this
still comes at a price and that price is
your sight anyone who looks directly at
the Dullahan will immediately be blinded
and even if you divert your gaze the
horseman will ensure that you never see
again by either throwing a bucket of
blood into your eyes or lashing him with
a whip made from a human spine neither
of which sound particularly fun now for
those of you thinking well that's fine
I'll just shut my eyes draw the curtains
and bolt the door
so the Dullahan can never get to me
sadly that wouldn't really work has all
manner of locks gates and windows fly
open when the horseman is near even if
you happen to be the greatest
hide-and-seek player of all time the
Dullahan simply only has to say your
name and you'll drop dead essentially
what I'm saying is if the Dullahan is
after you you may as well say goodbye to
your loved ones because you can't hide
and you certainly can't run but the
horseman does have one weakness an
aversion to gold so carrying around a
piece of gold such as a coin may buy you
some time but it certainly won't deter
him forever as we mentioned earlier
there are tales of the dullahan riding
through the countryside in a horse-drawn
carriage even being referred to as the
coachman to the afterlife
listen it's off is quite interesting
because it's a recurring theme that
we've seen other cultures across the
world
Greek mythology has its boatman and
Hermes Egypt has its guide an abyss
Japan has the Shinigami and in more
modern times we will know of the Grim
Reaper
the de'lon essentially performs the same
role except in his carriage that travels
so fast it would set fire to nearby
bushes and grass the carriages arrival
signaled the death of a family member
but unlike the Banshee that was seen
primarily as a warning
wherever the silent coach went and death
shortly followed I guess the one
question that most of you have been
waiting to be answered this entire video
is whether there's any significance
behind the dullahan being headless now
this could definitely just be to make
the Dullahan appear more terrifying but
I did come across some stories where the
Celtic people believed the head was
where the soul was located when an enemy
was defeated in battle their head would
be taken as a trophy because it was seen
as a great source of spiritual power and
protection from one's enemies and the
supernatural there have been quite a few
modern interpretations of the Dullahan
and the legend of the Headless Horseman
but one of the most famous being
Washington Irvine's The Legend of Sleepy
Hollow which was later adapted into a
film in 1999 it plays one of the idea
that the horseman can be enchanted and
manipulated into doing someone's bidding
killing people on their behalf it's
definitely an interesting read or watch
if the Headless Horseman is something
that does interest you there are so many
stories of the Headless Horseman from
all around the world that if you'd like
to see another video covering them all
then let me know in the comments below
as always I've been your host mythology
and fiction explained
[Music]
[Music]